so just inhale world I don't really know
too much about the Xenoblade franchise
but we just saw Xenoblade Chronicles on
the Wii U what do you what do you think
of this franchise this has been a year
of some really big RPGs and Xenoblade
Chronicles X just takes that to a whole
other level the world I think is going
to be bigger than the witcher bigger
than fallout and this is this going to
be a game that even getting into some of
the the basic nitty-gritty the coolest
stuff that you're seeing in trailers
that's going to take 30 to 40 hours and
that is actually my big take away with
this it's how much time it looks like
you need to sink into it so we managed
to see some mid game stuff for this
which is you know the time that you
actually get mex into the picture and
from what we saw that was between 20 and
40 hours depending on how you play the
game before you actually get to get to
that at a very minimum what are the
coolest things that we've seen our
armies maxima customization and the
battle options that's going to take a
long time to get into but I think once
you open it up the combat ability is and
the ways that you can customize your Mac
seem really excited again a lot of fun
one of the cool things that we asked
about and what we were looking at was
that once you buy these back some of
them are going to be really expensive
and there are lots of them down the line
but you're able to customize them make
them look however you want to from the
colors the weapon loadouts these you get
to really make your own as a player of
the first one did it seem a very
different in combat when you were
actually in a mecca pal from just being
bigger and more devastating did it
actually look or feel different to you
combat in the Xenoblade games feels a
little bit chaotic at times and the mech
doesn't change that a whole lot it does
make it seem like you're more powerful
which is a lot of fun like being able to
power through these enemies and just
cause widespread destruction but you can
only use your mac for a limited amount
of time so what both when you're
traveling through the game and when
you're in combat you're using up fuel
and you can use money to refuel or you
can just drive it back to your base but
sometimes you know if you're in the
middle of combat or if you're way far
away from everything and you just want
to do a little bit more exploring it's
gonna get a little bit costly to keep
going in your bed I'm speaking of
exploring if it looks like it's once
again going back
huge sort of open world in the first
game and it looked quite diverse we
visited quite a few continents during
this playthrough and you know we did
skip to the end the the demo we were
showing us this basically took us to the
end of his hundred and twenty our
playthrough and he still wasn't finished
then you know there was a there was a
huge range of different continents and I
think particularly different monsters
that were they were quite cool to
actually try and take on the wii game at
the time looked really beautiful but
having it on wii u i think is just gonna
take it to a whole other level maybe
this won't look as good as it does as a
game on xbox one or ps4 but soon oblate
Chronicles X looks really great on the
wii u a less powerful hardware and just
being able to see the scope of the world
flying around in these massive monsters
these massive bosses and just this huge
scope of the world and being able to
basically go anywhere without a lot of
cutscenes are a lot of a lot of loading
screens getting in the way I was super
impressed visually by it and some people
do forget that you know we you may be
the the lease sort of biggest technical
a console out there but can still pop
that some really nice graphics and I
think this one is really ematic event
and it really beats out the PDF it does
it does so obviously this game has been
at in Japan for a while but with the
Western release coming up real soon
right yeah coming out December forth so
people that maybe haven't gotten enough
open world adventures from The Witcher 3
expansions fallout 4 you're gonna be
able to dive into another really big
world coming up in December yeah if you
have 120 hours spare just you have made
sure to save it for Xenoblade Chronicles
X oh man gain of the year's gonna be so
hard this year
don't